how much money do you have one year $20  about you 10 I'm trying to live my dream  by preparing for three auditions back in  line I haven't even gotten a writing job  yet I've been taking on a bunch of  freelance - hey squirrel trying to buy  some lemonade I just need a money order  for $10 that'll be $20 I get a fee  because I have no money  yep so you're charging people for being  poor next those boys really care about  you don't they yes they do  you're my friends and I love you I just  don't know if I'm doing the right thing  out here I'm just gonna keep working  accept me for who I am  we've all maybe I truly believe it I  could see me now  look easy me and the mayor across the  sheet what up Playboy